all right so we just sit down we're just
gonna sit down ever done this I'm so
intrigued I've never done anything like
okay great so so there is a mother
energy that is present so if your mom is
not departed it would be like a
grandmother or an aunt or someone that
was like a mother to you it could
literally be any of those because
everyone died before I mean my mom is
like okay you're very fortunate because
you have not lost a lot of people here
in the physical world yeah I don't I
don't know many people that have passed
away right so yeah I can I talk about
the dead that's departed
oh my dad did die oh I don't know him oh
oh yeah all right okay I was gonna ask
you about pie I like pie cuz I think
they showed me cherry pie and I'm like
okay what am I supposed to say with that
I don't have a cherry pie is my sister's
thing but she's one he probably is
trying to talk to well we don't know
each other but you have to understand
your dad could not take responsibility
for things in his life here in the
Nevada one his soul is stepping forward
and saying I know what you felt I know
what you went through and for that I am
sorry
so I've already forgiven so I'm good but
I'm not like mad at it if you can hear I
was like like that's not what this is
about okay you have to understand it's
where someone if they heard us would
disappoint us if only if the soul has
learned the lesson you see things
differently they can come through and
say that so alright that's all my sister
for your dad to be able to come from
yeah Candace did lose someone yes
who are you she's my stylist oh hi nice
to meet you oh oh my god my very first
thing you said his mother and I was
thinking my life but her mother recently
passed that's right yeah were you
watching her breath in the end okay so
your mom just had speeches please tell
my daughter I know how much you so know
that your mom is showing me the bride
I'm watching you breathe
so she says please I want to thank you
for releasing my soul here in the
physical world and that was the hardest
thing that you had to do was to let me
go and the way that you fixed my hair
and rubbed my face
after I died she says I want to thank
you
your mom talks though about her jewelry
so do you have my gosh I'm talking about
her to worry like to have voiceless she
says I want to thank you and I know and
I wear her new perfect did you take her
blanket so random how would she know
that I'm freaked out about the presents
Teresa I was like not my mom's rocking
in North Carolina she's good like I was
saying in my head but it wasn't me
because you see can you kept looking off
and you said well maybe it's not you cuz
I'm looking off and usually cuz it means
it's not with me right right and you're
a mom have you spent and we you had
literally been going through this like
yeah for the past year it's been pretty
brutal yeah she died unexpectedly so I
wasn't prepared obviously and I had just
had a baby and I had serious postpartum
depression and so this last year was a
huge struggle not having her around to
be there with my newborn baby - what did
that mean to you though cuz that was I I
felt it in the room that was crazy
one the jewelry nobody knows about
because a family member of mine wanted
to keep it and I was like no I want to
take my mother's show me my daughter's
gonna have that jewelry klepto you got
the blanket - yeah that's the thing
nobody knows about is my grandmother
crocheted this blanket for my mother and
she always used it on the couch reading
and stuff like that so I kind of just
snuck it into my wardrobe case second
funeral and took it home and I was like
told my husband's family I was like I
got this blanket but no but like I don't
even I think I might have told his mom
like nobody knows that and she was
saying today my mom was
I know you have the blanket and I know
that you snuggle with it at night and
that broke me because you know I was on
the fence at first I don't know but like
nobody knows that nobody I told my
husband on the phone today I was like it
was so amazing and also really freaky
yeah yes my mom is literally creeping on
me I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this